ah Brésil la belle maison ensoleillée
des organes génitaux sans poils de Pelé et la
plus grande statue de Jared Leto au
monde pour montrer mon dévouement aux légions de
fans brésiliens de Deadpool
J'ai passé jusqu'à 20 minutes sur Google
Translate ainsi que d'innombrables heures à
regarder des telenovelas pour
tout m'apprendre  à propos de votre langue officielle,
c'est vrai, mais je vous vois cette tâche sexy en
spandex rouge, apprenez à parler portugais,
j'espère que j'obtiendrai l'accent juste ici.
Un co-sponsor de classe M a
prononcé son propre RSS.
o
mas odorant o menos de connaissances
préserver sakoku nukemama Bella Terra
Bella comme un gourou elle a consenti une laisse
Vogons un oreiller Co Co Co Co Masha Kiran
comiXology frigo orange ml Apache cave
I say complètement innover
Costa nada assassin Erin contrato
Dispenza
se prepara regard Rai  Bachchan nouveau Baku
mahjong Falacci de science porque Hamada
saison 5 cocoon potins ressemblant à un mo
kamo Mo Kio temple ami Am  homme GData
eden samba pelon famiglia
mine de marais Comanche spécifique Karin caca d'éléphant
taka Fatima ha ha Gullu
Peloso pi ish c'est mon opportunité a parlé
à des modélisateurs pres propres suggérer Oprah a
fait un vase ou Chima Je ne dirai jamais que
je suis un Suki be don  ne touchez pas une autre Enya, vous êtes
juste parce que je suis un farceur,
regardez-moi droit dans les mamelons et dites-
moi que je ne viens pas de clouer ça maintenant qu'attendez-
vous pour aller sur le site Web ci-dessous
pour réserver votre place et vous êtes sûr de
être le sujet de discussion de l'espace de South Paulo est
limité, alors dépêchez-vous car je pense que nous
pouvons tous convenir qu'il n'y a rien de tel qu'une
journée ou une nuit sauvage au Brésil pour créer un
souvenir spécial que vous chérirez
pour toujours, il
suffit de demander à l'équipe de natation masculine américaine 2016
ils '  Je te ferai probablement de la merde
Jojo